[Music]
it repelled adventure news witho okay I
don't know that is submitted by dancing
panda dancing merely embrace it that's
weird to see you smile
I'm never smashing it really hard right
now her logo was a was this was a panda
what happened to that logo I like that
guy it started becoming derogatory
towards myself Rachel I made my own
racial thing I slanted the eyes allotted
too much penile opium in the mouth is
weird understood a man jumped on a tow
truck in a desperate attempt to stop his
car from being literally pull zest oh
these are the best stories man like I
remember watching this repo men show and
like TLC or some [ __ ] oh yeah oh that
[ __ ] was so sick well no it was just
like like someone would be at a gas
station like refilling their car and
they just [ __ ] tow truck it away is
amazing like in some times I saw one
word like the hose was still in the car
the nozzle got ripped off the thing okay
that sounds fake I saw this one episode
where they repoed a car from a karate
studio and all the karate students came
out and started doing like karate no
they were doing like perfect flips and
karate moves
aggressively no those girls just so
happened that these karate girls came
out and then it was like what was that
like this seventh season cuz like the
first seasons usually got real and then
after a while like they have to keep
making episodes
that by the way is exactly how effective
karate is yeah like how many fights have
you been where you'd like to a perfect
form yeah it was perfect form and it was
like those trickshot kicks to where
they're spinning like eight times in the
air what were you trying to do they were
trying to repossess a angry karate
teachers like car or something all the
students were like we got your back
teacher yeah yeah they wouldn't let them
leave and then like they were just my
job Rangers yeah all that stuff and you
know what it plays into like this this
morbid sickness so we have of seeing
poor people like somehow put put down
another rung in the ladder it's so true
that's what it is it's like the next
show is like that they should make is
like poor people getting parking tickets
like they go to the windshield they're
like cap on their car so like they don't
even they can't drive their car anymore
they already poor [ __ ] they can't go to
work they get a boot going on yeah boot
damn dude that's all by the way that's
all street-sweeping Elias creativity is
just a poor people tasks rich people
already have [ __ ] driveways parking
spots living like better areas where
there's no street sweeping but you know
what I'm a [ __ ] call this [ __ ] out
because I got a street-sweeping ticket
and the thing is I wanted to contest it
right I tried for five consecutive days
to contest it on the website I wanted to
call there these [ __ ] out Saul so
pissed I called him and I was like hey
your website's not working no sometimes
it does that I was like well I want to
click the appeal button but it just goes
to error they're just saying that I have
to send like a snail mail and I'm like
who the [ __ ] does that these days no one
writes a [ __ ] me they make it yeah
they and then I was like you know what I
don't I don't want to do it I'm just
gonna pay the 50 bucks
I had a boot on my car when I first
moved to LA well because I could afford
it
how is it like you escalates again if
you get the ticket then it doubles if
you don't pay it then it doubles again
then it doubles again so it's like
[ __ ] nuts right that shouldn't even
be legal it's like reverse martingale
methods oh my god nuts you just left
your car there so I got the boot
it was just like parked on the street
because it's the only place I had to
park because I was not I did not have an
apartment where I could even park
because my girlfriend at the time parked
two there because I'm a man and we're in
Koreatown and I'm not gonna let her walk
around it's not a man if you can't
predict ISM right Koreatown does have
good burn good Murr no so yeah so then I
get I get the boot on and then like you
know I had to like go borrow money and
[ __ ] and pay it hard time keeping him
down so in Compton there was this man I
just jumped on top of a repo truck or
the tow truck that was repossessing his
car and that's when there was this car
that saw all this happen this couple and
they started filming it on their cell
phone I'm gonna show you guys the video
was he screaming NWA hey and someone
behind I was like eh because they're
from Compton okay here we go and the
repo driver says crowbar to smash in the
rear window
stop the car you spoke [ __ ] [ __ ]
hold the tow truck over and only then
does Reid finally jump down you can see
the bear rims on the car at the end well
yeah
he's doing hairpin turns of that
function thing so who do the cops
confront the guy who's more stupid I
wanted to find out some more too cuz I'm
like dude the tow truck driver he has to
be punished somehow that was super
dangerous you should have just stopped
well if he stopped a guy with a crowbar
bashed in his window he was already yeah
that tow truck driver watches Dog the
Bounty Hunter and he's like this guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] do you speed up Oh land
the brake and the guy flies off see I
would have been the tow truck driver
just trying to shake them off like the
car was fish selling a lot dad I think
the cables just ripped on the car but
the guy was still holding on strong like
give me my [ __ ] car [ __ ]
that's crazy that was kind of cool
that's a cooler video a lot that I've
seen lately and the people filming were
just like just driving behind me yeah
there are two cards following the the
tow truck just trying to film everything
cuz they're just like you can't believe
what I'm seeing
they actually drove for ten minutes like
that from convent at Long Beach good for
them for filming in the right aspect
ratio Oh seriously thank you no
landscape and perfect HD thank you
what does it take to get things repo'd
like do you miss your payments how long
this man he missed his payment only like
for one month
no way well then he had like bad I was
bad situation with them already you
already had bad credit or something and
they were like we'll give you a car but
don't [ __ ] your high rents but we'll do
it people can miss a month of payment
and be like oh I forgot and then they'll
call the company and pay it back no hard
feelings I don't know any car yeah it
can't be one month I had a repo guy come
for my truck one time because I got that
oh my god what was it one month of
missed payment or was it like six it was
two
a half months that maybe a little bit
more sent in and did you not respond or
communicate he it was at my my parents
address because I had just moved to LA
and so the guy like showed up in my
dad's door and he's like I'm here to
repossess the truck or whatever and my
dad's like I don't know if I were
talking about because my dad's a [ __ ]
pimp legend called you gonna pay the
game thing is like whatever you got to
do got a pair and so I did that's dope
yeah your dad's not a rapper [ __ ]
baddest he's no rat yeah he's not gonna
narc on my ass I had to pick my
ex-boyfriend up from jail one time
because know you like to choose him
right huh Wow no no he um he's like the
nicest looking guy like you know
Hawaiian shirt on put it out anyway he's
called me really two videos ago there's
a weird head shape it's awful anyway he
I guess had over $1,000 of parking
tickets that were unpaid and so like
when a cop pulled him over for like a
stop not stopping all the way or
something like that something minor he
looks up his driver's license and he's
got all these unpaid parking tickets and
so he just took him to jail and like
they like took his card to like an
impound or whatever and yeah and so he
wasn't allowed to even like call me or
anything like he was supposed to pick us
pick me up for a date and I hadn't heard
from him I thought he was like in an
accident or something yeah I was like
staying at his buddy's house like have
you heard from him and we were just both
like waiting to like hear from this guy
and he calls it like 2:00 in the morning
like I ended up like just crashing on
the couch there and he calls it like
2:00 in the morning like I'm in jail can
you come pick me up and I'm like holy
[ __ ] what happened he's just like unpaid
parking tickets
and he had a thousand dollars in cash on
him like can I just give this to you and
they wouldn't know they had to do all
his paperwork [ __ ] me tell you
something so he spent like the night in
jail
like he won the lotto at his works like
a lot of they do a Friday lotto or like
you put up percentage of your paycheck
it's just the most gold on the earth
right here
that was a [ __ ] drug dealer he had
flushed with cash by the way unpaid
parking tickets story and that I have
$1,000 cash on him he talked about the
lotto thing every week though like there
was a thing like he never won this lotto
setting up the cover I can't handle it
Nicky so what about this ether stuff is
that real water what's real ëthere iam
these bitcoins I'm talking about cuz I'm
falling for that question is what was
his ethnicity he was half Filipino half
way breakdancing drug dealer
yeah he's basically Mexican so he was
like a 6-foot he looked white he looked
like a tan white guy he was six foot one
huge dick like huge day just the worst
day of my whole life
he was riffle just totally ripped can't
believe this is happening
like totally he's definitely bigger than
yours of course is a huge after she said
it to the three fives a loser vagina
look you couldn't do anything with it in
the first place dig was too big hey guys
thanks for watching that last video make
sure to follow us on instagram @ JK
films to watch more videos right up
there
[Music]